Comme beaucoup d'architectes, David aime être sous les feux de la rampe
mais il est discret, ou fait semblant de l'être,
donc il préfère que je l'interroge plutôt que de faire un long discours.
En fait, ce dont nous allons parler
est un sujet qui se prête mieux à une conversation je pense,
qu'à un exposé.
Je crois que nous avons un sujet à visionner pour commencer.
Depuis les attentats du 11 septembre sur le World Trade Center
beaucoup de gens se sont rendus dans le centre de New York
pour rendre hommage aux victimes, sur ce cimetière de 6 hectares.
Aujourd'hui, comme l'explique Jim Axelrod de CBS, ils mettent la touche finale
à une nouvelle installation pour que les visiteurs puissent voir.
Oubliez l'Empire State Building ou la Statue de la Liberté
A New York, le lieu
où la foule est la plus compacte est Ground Zero.
J'ai emmené ma belle-fille depuis Indianapolis.
Parmi tous les sites touristiques de New York
c'était ce qu'elle voulait voir.
Des milliers de personnes font la queue sur Lower Broadway.
Je voulais venir depuis que c'est arrivé.
Même en plein hiver, dans le froid,
pour rendre hommage et se souvenir.
C'est la réalité, c'est nous. C'est arrivé ici.
Ceci est à nous.
Il y a tant de monde, que voir le site est devenu
un vrai problème.
Je pense que les gens sont vraiment frustrés
de ne pas pouvoir s'approcher davantage.
Mais cela va changer.
En un temps record,
une équipe d'architectes et d'ouvriers du bâtiment
ont imaginé et construit une plate-forme d'observation pour apaiser les frustrations,
et permettre à tous de s'approcher.
Ils auront une vue incroyable.
Je crois qu'ils comprendront mieux
la totale destruction de cet endroit.
Quand on y pense, Ground Zero est différent des
autres sites touristiques d'Amérique.
Différent du Grand Canyon ou du Washington Monument
car les gens viennent voir ce qui n'est plus là.
David Rockwell: Ce que les gens verront,
en arrivant ici, ce n'est pas un chantier,
mais un cimetière incroyablement émouvant.
Les murs sont intentionnellement nus, pour que les gens
puissent déposer leurs messages, comme ils le font déjà
autour de l'actuel périmètre.
Ca nous a touché en plein coeur.
Pour les passerelles, on a utilisé des matériaux très simples
comme le contreplaqué qu'on utilise sur les chantiers,
c'est tout l'intérêt.
Face à la plus grande destruction que l'Amérique ait connu,
les gens reconstruisent.
Jim Axelrod, CBS news, à New York.
Ce n'est pas évident de parler ici de sensualité,
mais on vous considère David, même si je sais que vous détestez cette expression,
comme un architecte du divertissement.
Votre travail est hautement sensuel, hédoniste même.
J'aime bien ce mot là.
Votre travail est lié au plaisir, les casinos, les hôtels, les restaurants.
Comment ce choc que tout le monde a ressenti, surtout nous à New York,
le 11 septembre, a-t-il provoqué chez vous
cette envie de faire tout ça?
Et bien la vérité, c'est qu'après le 11 septembre,
j'ai considéré tout d'abord
que comme je vis à Tribeca,
un quartier qui a été dévasté,
et que je travaille à moins de 2 km de là,
c'était mon rôle de forcer les 100 personnes qui travaillent avec moi,
dans mon entreprise, à garder le même enthousiasme
que nous avons toujours eu dans notre travail.
Nous terminons un livre qui s'appelle "Plaisir",
qui parle de plaisir sensuel dans certains espaces.
Mais je dois dire que c'était devenu impossible.
Nous étions comme paralysés.
Et je me suis retrouvé le vendredi suivant le 11 septembre,
deux jours après,
littéralement incapable de motiver qui que ce soit.
Nous avons tous pris quelques jours de congé.
En parlant de ça avec d'autres architectes,
on a lu dans la presse que des gens pensaient
que les tours devaient être reconstruites à l'identique,
en y ajoutant 50 étages.
Et j'ai trouvé ça incroyable d'avoir des projets,
comme s'il s'agissait d'une compétition,
à propos d'une blessure si récente.
J'ai beaucoup discuté
d'abord avec Rick Scofidio et Liz Diller, qui ont travaillé avec nous,
et avec d'autres personnes ensuite,
et je me suis dit qu'il fallait vraiment que tout ça ait un intérêt.
En tant qu'architectes, la seule vraie façon d'aider
n'était pas de parader ou d'élaborer des scénarios,
mais d'aider les gens tout de suite.
Alors on a essayé de trouver un moyen,
de créer un genre de groupe d'intervention d'architectes.
Et voilà ce qui en est sorti.
Etiez-vous conscient que tout à coup,
en tant que designer dont le travail est de satisfaire des envies,
vous alliez devoir satisfaire des besoins?
Ce dont j'étais conscient,
c'est qu'il y avait un besoin urgent d'agir.
On nous avait demandé de participer à quelques projets avant ça.
Il y avait une école, PS 234, qui avait été évacuée à Ground Zero.
Ils ont déménagé dans une école désaffectée.
On a réuni 20 ou 30 architectes, des designers, des artistes,
et ça a pris 4 jours, comme quand les gens construisaient des granges,
tout le monde a voulu apporter son aide pour la rénover.
C'était extraordinaire.
Tom Otterness et Maira Kalman ont contribué à ce projet,
et c'est devenu une expérience cathartique.
Ca a été terminé en 3 semaines
vers le 8 octobre c'est ça?
Oui.
Je suppose qu'en vous attaquant à un projet
aussi considérable, en plus des trois autres
que vous avez imaginé pour encadrer le site,
vous avez dû vous heurter à une administration et une autorité
complexes et bien ancrées dans les milieux
de l'immobilier et de la politique à New York?
Et bien, c'est bizarre.
Quand on a fini PS 234, on a dîné avec quelques personnes.
On m'avait demandé de présider l'Institut Américain d'Architecture pour la reconstruction.
J'ai assisté à plusieurs réunions.
On y évoquait les projets les plus grandioses et compliqués
qui impliqueraient des travaux à long terme et la reconstruction complète de la ville.
Mais il y avait des blessures et des besoins auxquels il fallait s'attaquer de suite,
et eux parlaient d'intégrer ça à un processus global.
Ce n'était pas un groupe facile à intégrer.
Alors on a dit...
Ce n'était pas un groupe facile à intégrer?
Ce n'était pas un groupe facile à intégrer.
Principalement blancs, riches, du milieu des affaires,
qui ne représentaient pas la ville.
C'est choquant!
Oui, très surprenant.
Alors Rick, Liz, Kévin et moi on a eu une idée.
La municipalité nous a contacté.
Nous avions d'abord contacté la municipalité au sujet de la Jetée 94.
Nous avons vu comment PS 234 a fonctionné.
Les familles, les familles de victimes,
se rendaient sur cette jetée incroyablement dégradante.
Sur la rivière Hudson?
Oui. Et la municipalité, d'abord Tim Zagat,
puis Christyne Nicholas, et finalement on est arrivé à Giuliani,
nous a dit: "on ne veut pas s'occuper de la Jetée 94 pour l'instant,
mais il y a une plate-forme d'observation pour les familles à Ground Zero
dont on aimerait faire quelque chose de plus digne pour les familles,
et trouver un moyen de la protéger du mauvais temps.
Alors je suis allé voir avec Rick, Liz et Kévin,
et je dois dire que ça a été une des expériences les plus émouvantes de ma vie.
C'était bouleversant de voir cette simple plate-forme en contreplaqué entourée d'une barrière,
où les familles de victimes avaient déposé des messages.
Nous n'étions pas préparé à une telle expérience.
Il n'y avait aucun filtre.
Je me suis souvenu du 11 septembre, sur la 14ème rue,
on voyait très bien les tours du toit de notre bâtiment,
j'ai vu la première tour s'effondrer depuis la salle de conférence
au 8ème étage, à la télé.
Tout le monde s'est précipité sur le toit, moi aussi.
Ce qui est incroyable, c'est que c'est beaucoup plus dur
de croire en la réalité qu'en ce qu'on voit à la télé.
Ca fait moins peur quand il y a un filtre
quand on a des informations sur ce qui se passe à côté de soi.
C'est pour ça que voir la plate-forme simplement,
dignement, ça a été une expérience bouleversante.
Donc on est retourné voir la municipalité et on leur a dit
que ça ne nous intéressait pas d'en faire une plate-forme pour VIP,
mais on a passé du temps là-bas.
Et puis la municipalité avait ce besoin.
Ils cherchaient une solution
pour gérer les 30 ou 40 000 personnes par jour
qui allaient là-bas sans pouvoir voir.
Et puis il fallait gérer la circulation autour du site.
S'occuper de ça, c'était l'objectif n°1.
Il fallait trouver un moyen pour que les gens
puissent se déplacer aux alentours.
Mais ensuite il vous a fallu trouver un moyen,
sans parler de la complexité du système d'obtention des permis
et de mettre tout le monde d'accord, pour financer tout ça.
Ca a l'air assez simple.
Cependant il s'agit d'un projet d'un demi milliard de dollars.
En fait, on savait que sans fonds privés,
ça n'aboutirait pas.
Et franchement, on savait aussi que si ça n'aboutissait pas
avant la fin du mandat de Giuliani,
alors tous nos contacts au ministère des transports,
aux services de police, et...
On voyait 20 ou 30 personnes de la municipalité à la fois.
C'est le Bureau de Gestion des Urgences qui organisait.
Ils ont fait du bon boulot, ils voulaient vraiment que ça marche,
ils ont senti qu'il y avait un besoin.
C'est pour ça qu'il y avait urgence?
Parce que Giuliani ne serait plus là 3 mois plus tard?
Oui. Donc la première chose à faire pour y arriver,
c'était travailler avec les familles de victimes,
par le biais de la municipalité, pour qu'elles sachent ce qui se passait.
On ne voulait pas que ça soit une surprise.
Il fallait faire en sorte d'être le plus transparent possible,
parce que le but n'était pas de soulever des objections
mais de travailler aussi tranquillement que possible.
L'idée nous est venue de créer une fondation,
surtout parce que quand on a trouvé l'entrepreneur,
il a refusé de le faire malgré l'argent que nous étions prêts à lui donner.
Il fallait qu'il y ait une fondation.
Donc on a crée cette fondation, et ce qui s'est passé,
c'est qu'un promoteur important à New York...
Qui restera anonyme je suppose?
Oui. Ses initiales sont JS, il est le propriétaire du Rockfeller Center,
si vous voulez un indice, a proposé son aide.
On l'a rencontré.
Les prix des entrepreneurs allaient de 500 à 700 000 dollars.
Et Atlantic-Heydt, la plus grande entreprise d'échafaudage du pays,
a proposé de travailler sans bénéfices.
Donc notre promoteur a dit "nous couvrirons toutes les dépenses."
On a répondu, "Incroyable!"
Je crois que c'était le 21,
et il fallait qu'on ait fini avant le 28.
On était censés commencer le lendemain.
On a fait une réunion le soir avec l'entrepreneur qu'il avait choisi,
qui est arrivé avec les dessins d'une plate-forme
2 fois plus petite que celle qu'on avait dessinée.
Comme dans le film Spinal Tap où il y a
un tout petit Stonehenge, c'est ça?
-
En réalité, on aurait dit un échafaudage de laveurs de vitres.
On ne sentait pas que cet endroit, tout proche de Saint Paul,
dégagé la dignité nécessaire
à un lieu de recueillement et de souvenir.
Je dois dire qu'on a passé beaucoup de temps
à mettre tout ça en place, à observer les gens qui se réunissaient à St Paul,
sur la droite, et qui se déplaçaient autour du site.
Je vis là bas, alors on a passé du temps à définir les besoins.
Je crois que les gens ont été surpris par 2 choses:
Ils ont été surpris par la destruction,
et ils n'arrivaient pas à croire en
la force et le courage des New Yorkais, ça m'a beaucoup ému.
Le courage au quotidien des New Yorkais.
Donc pendant cette réunion, l'entrepreneur a carrément dit,
"Je ferme la porte à clé, parce que ce promoteur
ne vous laissera pas partir tant que vous n'aurez pas signé."
On lui a dit: " C'est 2 fois trop petit,
il n' y a aucune des caractéristiques prévues,
sur lesquelles tout le monde était d'accord, à la municipalité.
Il faudrait tout reprendre à zéro pour faire ça."
Je l'ai convaincu de nous laisser sortir avec l'accord
de construire ce qui avait été prévu.
Le lendemain j'ai reçu un mail du promoteur
disant qu'il retirait tous ses fonds.
On ne savait pas quoi faire,
alors on a décidé de ratisser très large.
On a envoyé des mails à autant de personnes que possible,
certaines d'entre elles sont ici, elles ont beaucoup aidé.
Vous n'avez pas envisagé de quitter le navire à ce moment là?
Non. En fait j'ai dit à l'entrepreneur de continuer.
Il avait déjà commandé des matériaux sur mon accord.
On savait que d'une façon ou d'une autre, ça allait marcher.
On sentait qu'il fallait que ça marche.
Vous vous êtes auto-financés donc, avec les dons et cette fondation.
Richard, de manière très claire,
a fait le rapprochement tout à l'heure,
avec les designers de chaises,
ces designers de chaises qui imposent des arguments esthétiques
sur un point aussi commun, banal et universel que celui de s'asseoir.
Il me semble que ceci
est exactement l'opposé.
C'était un problème de design singulier et sans précédent.
C'est là toute la question.
On savait que ça n'était pas dans le sens...
On pense au site, et au besoin d'un mémorial.
Enfin pas exactement un mémorial.
C'est un endroit où les gens se recueillent et se souviennent,
un endroit tranquille.
Ce qui nous a amené à utiliser le design
pour limiter les barrières entre le public,
comme pour la plate forme des familles, et l'expérience elle même.
Les matériaux sont incroyablement simples.
Des échafaudages et du contreplaqué.
Ce qui permet, grâce au mouvement des personnes
allant jusqu'à St Paul et redescendant par l'autre côté,
de parcourir près de 100 m pour arriver à 4 m du sol,
d'où on a une vue de 360 degrés.
Ce design découle d'impératifs de rapidité, de coût, de sécurité, de respect et de flexibilité.
Il est également prévu que cette architecture puisse être déplacée.
En effet, on a observé les 4 plate-formes existantes,
l'une d'entre elles, une amélioration de celle prévue pour les familles,
nous a permis de comprendre qu'elles devaient pouvoir bouger
pour répondre aux diverses conditions
et aux changements que connaîtrait Ground Zero.
Votre travail, nous en avons déjà parlé,
est guidé par le fait que vous vous concentrez sur
l'aspect temporaire et évanescent des choses.
"Carpe Diem, on ne sait jamais de quoi demain sera fait",
c'est comme ça que vous voyez les choses.
Ce projet ne traversera clairement pas les âges.
Dans quelques années, cette chose ne sera plus là.
En tant qu'architecte, cela a-t-il exigé
de votre part une nouvelle façon de voir les choses?
De considérer cela comme une installation temporaire?
Non, je ne crois pas.
Je crois que de toute évidence, c'est totalement différent
de tout ce qu'on a fait auparavant, de par sa nature.
Il y a 2 types de réflexions sur notre travail en général:
premièrement, la notion de collaboration est impérative pour avancer.
Kevin Kennon, Rick Scofidio, Liz Diller
et tous les gens de la municipalité,
Norman Lear, avec qui j'ai discuté 4 heures avant d'atteindre la limite pour trouver les financements,
nous a offert un prêt relais pour nous permettre d'y arriver.
Donc la notion de collaboration
est essentielle je pense.
En ce qui concerne l'aspect temporaire,
notre but n'était pas de créer quelque chose
qui resterait là plus longtemps que nécessaire.
Ce qui nous intéressait c'était de promouvoir une sorte de dialogue
qui n'avait peut être pas suffisamment existé dans cette ville,
sur ce qui se passe réellement là bas.
1 jour ou 2 avant l'ouverture, Giuliani a fait son discours d'adieu,
où il a évoqué l'idée de faire de tout Ground Zero un mémorial.
Idée très controversée, mais qui a trouvé un écho auprès de beaucoup.
Indépendamment de la position à adopter au sujet
de ce qu'on doit faire de cet endroit sacré,
l'évoquer au moment où on découvre le résultat devant ses yeux,
rend le dialogue plus percutant.
C'est ça qui nous intéressait.
Tout cela fait partie intégrante de tout ce à quoi
je me suis intéressé auparavant.
Entre autres choses, cela me semble un bel exemple d'infrastructure civique.
Cela rend cette conversation sérieuse.
6 mois après les faits,
quelques mois seulement après que le site ait été dégagé,
nous arrivons rapidement au stade où
il faut se demander sérieusement ce que nous allons faire de cet endroit.
Après vous être tant impliqué physiquement sur le site,
avez-vous des idées concernant ce qui
devrait ou pas être fait?
Je pense qu'il ne faut pas faire d'estimation.
Je pense que les discussions dans les milieux autorisés portent sur le plan d'ensemble.
La Protetch Gallery a récemment présenté ses idées de bâtiments,
qui pour certaines sont très inventives.
Et d'autres vraiment mauvaises.
Ça ressemble un peu à une compétition d'idées,
alors qu'il faudrait se concentrer sur un plan d'ensemble et une utilisation.
Avoir une vue d'ensemble, ça commence à être le cas.
Le dialogue s'élargit vraiment sur
ce qu'on veut réellement faire du site.
Je crois sincèrement que quand on aura résolu la question du mémorial,
ce sera difficile d'avoir une discussion intelligente.
Certaines discussions en ce moment sont très positives,
comme l'idée d'enterrer l'autoroute du West Side de façon à
avoir une vue ouverte sur l'espace.
En effet, c'est intéressant.
Ce qui nous mène à une autre question qu'il aurait été indélicat
d'évoquer il y a 6 mois, mais c'est différent maintenant,
car peu d'entre nous aimaient le World Trade Center du point de vue architectural,
pour ce qu'il avait fait à la ville, et cette immense place.
Est-ce l'occasion, le côté positif
s'il y en a un, de reconstruire
quelque chose de plus traditionnel?
J'y vois une vraie occasion d'engager une discussion
sur les raisons pour lesquelles nous vivons dans les villes.
Pourquoi vivons-nous dans des endroits où des gens si différents
nous croisent tous les jours?
Ca n'a pas grand chose à voir avec 50, 60, 70 ou 80 000 nouveaux bureaux,
peu importe le nombre.
Alors oui, c'est une occasion de reconsidérer ce que nous pensons des villes.
En fait, il y a un projet sur la table pour reconstruire numéro 7.
Le bâtiment qui était au nord des tours?
C'est ça, les Tours se sont effondrées dessus.
Le projet est en suspend à cause de l'indignation de la communauté,
c'est pour ça qu'ils ne réouvrent pas la rue
pour relier cet endroit avec le reste de la ville.
C'est pourquoi je pense qu'une concertation publique...
J'aimerais qu'il y ait un concours international,
un appel aux idées.
Que ce soit de l'art, du logement,
ou même du shopping?
Oui et nous cherchons d'autres idées.
La petite fondation que nous avons créée cherche d'autres façons d'aider.
Y compris prendre une petite partie adjacente au site
et inviter 10 architectes qui n'ont pour l'instant pas voix au chapitre,
à venir ici pour en faire des ateliers d'artistes.
Trouver d'autres moyens d'encourager la discussion
pour éviter des solutions trop simple ou trop massives
et développer une multitude de choses.
Avant de conclure, vous avez je crois une vidéo montrant
ce qui se passe sur la plate-forme?
John Kamen, qui est ici, a monté 2 mn 30 de vidéo
qui montre la plate-forme maintenant qu'elle est ouverte.
Ca me paraissait bien de finir là dessus.
Nous sommes au dessus de Fulton Street, à l'ouest.
Une des difficultés que nous avons rencontrées avec l'administration Giuliani
c'est que j'avais oublié à quel point il est contre les graffitis.
Cette structure a été créée pour qu'on puisse écrire dessus.
Comme vous dites, ce n'est pas un mémorial.
Mais aviez vous en tête d'autres mémoriaux? Celui du Vietnam?
Ce genre de format?
Nous avons fait un grand travail de recherches,
et nous avions d'autres mémoriaux en tête.
En particulier concernant la complexité et la durée de réalisation.
Il y a 350 personnes membres du comité pour Oklahoma City,
c'est pourquoi nous avons trouvé que c'était une solution appropriée et spontanée
qui s'étendait entre Union Square
et les endroits qui se trouvaient déjà être des mémoriaux appropriés.
Cet échafaudage construit au dessus de la rue est démontable.
Ce qui est intéressant c'est que la nature du site a totalement changé,
pour qu'on soit conscient
qu'il ne s'agit pas seulement de la destructions de 2 bâtiments,
mais de tous les autres autour de Ground Zero,
et que les cicatrices sur ces bâtiments sont énormes.
On voit St Paul à gauche.
Je tiens à vous remercier au nom des New Yorkais
d'avoir rendu tout ceci possible, de l'avoir fait.
Le fait que tout cela ait été érigé presque instantanément,
le fait d'être là,
avant même qu'on envisage
qu'une solution d'une telle envergure pouvait être apportée,
contribue à son extraordinaire
beauté, ou tout au moins,
sa présence.
Ce fut un honneur pour moi.
Nous sommes ravis d'avoir pu le montrer ici.